Jean-Luc bourlange bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous le 24 février 2022
3h48 du matin la Russie envahissait
l'Ukraine nous nous sommes réveillés tôt
et nous ne nous sommes pas endormis
depuis le 24 février 2022 a commencé le
jour le plus long de notre vie disait
hier soir volodimeer Zelinski Emmanuel
Macron a tweeté ce matin
ukrainait ukrainien la France se tient à
vos côtés à la solidarité à la victoire
et à la paix Jean-Louis bourlange depuis
un an le monde était branlé l'ordre
mondial était branlé oui qui lui dit
qu'il est cru il y a un an certains ne
croyaient pas à la guerre d'autres dont
moi ils croyaient pensaient que Poutine
n'avait plus d'autre choix au point où
il était allé que de faire la guerre
mais combien penser que un an plus tard
la Grande Armée Rouge serait
enliser incapable de conquérir ce pays
de taille modeste personne personne ne
le pensait et les Ukrainiens nous ont
donné une une formidable leçon et cette
leçon elle s'explique en partie par le
contenu de votre question c'est à dire
que derrière cela il y a quand même
toute une idée de la démocratie de
l'homme en réalité du droit de la
liberté qui fait que nous nous sommes
tous directement pour les Ukrainiens
indirectement pour l'ensemble des
Occidentaux mobiliser derrière
l'Ukraine et on voit bien que il y a
deux lectures de l'avenir du monde qui
s'affrontent en ce moment dans les
plaines ukrainiennes regardons les faits
Vladimir Poutine
n'avait n'a pas rempli ses objectifs
objectif initiaux devl Vladimir Poutine
conquérir la majeure partie du
territoire ukrainien renverser le
installé au pouvoir à Kiev un pouvoir à
la solde de Moscou c'était l'objectif de
Vladimir Poutine objectif qu'il n'a pas
atteint objectif militaire et objectifs
politiques ça c'est un fait aujourd'hui
la Chine la oui la Chine revient dans le
jeu je veux dire par là que ce matin la
Russie est isolée mais la Chine revient
dans le jeu je vous parlais d'ordre
mondial ébranlé la Chine
a proposé ce matin une sorte de plan de
paix pas tout à fait un plan de fait de
paix Jean-Luc bourlange que dit Pékin
Pékin appelle la Russie et l'Ukraine à
reprendre le dialogue direct Pékin
s'oppose à tout recours à l'arme
nucléaire Pékin demande aux deux pays
d'éviter toute attaque contre les civils
Pékin insiste sur le respect de la
souveraineté de toute les nations
insuffisantes oui enfin je crois que
Pékin je crois que pour revenir à la au
bilan d'un an je crois qu'on doit dire
il y a une formule que j'ai entendu qui
est pas de moi mais que je trouve très
juste la Russie n'a pas gagné donc elle
a perdu l'Ukraine n'a pas perdu donc
elle a gagné je pense que ça définit
assez bien la situation depuis un an et
en même temps et c'est là où ça débouche
sur le problème là les perspectives de
traiter de paix de négociation notamment
celle qui sont évoquées par les Chinois
nous sommes donc dans une situation qui
n'est pas décisive sur le plan sur le
plan politique la Russie n'a pas perdue
si elle avait vraiment perdu si elle
avait vraiment perdu nous pourrions
imposer des négociations bien entendu la
Russie a perdu parce que vraiment ne pas
gagner quand on est la Russie avec
l'armée qui était la Cavée la réputation
de l'Armée rouge les forces immenses la
supériorité démographique la supériorité
économique le fait qu'en face d'un pays
qui n'avait aucune puissance nucléaire à
tout ça crée un déséquilibre
qui ne s'est pas concrétiser mais là
vous avez raison c'est que la situation
est une situation aujourd'hui
d'équilibre or et là où les Chinois ou
la perspective chinoise est un peu
irréaliste même si c'est intéressant
qu'elle soit formulée car moi je suis de
ceux qui pensent que seul une
modification du rapport de force dans un
sens où est la dans l'autre pourrait
amener à des négociations de paix si
prenons la mauvaise hypothèse si
l'Ukraine s'effondre si on a une grande
offensive russe qui s'emparait de dessin
etc ou qui avec le concours de la
Biélorussie arriverait sur Kiev
les Ukrainiens serait bien obligés de
négocier même si en fait la paix qui
serait négociée serait une paix
de extrêmement de guerre civile
permanente mais bon ça ça serait la très
mauvaise hypothèse l'autre hypothèse les
russes seront bien obligés de négocier
si les Ukrainiens
reconquèrent l'essentiel de ce qu'ils
ont perdu et
constitue une menace et menace en
réalité la Crimée et donc le problème de
tous ces plans de paix comme le plan
chinois ils arrivent à un moment où
aucun des protagonistes ne peut les
entendre en 1904
quand l'armée allemande le quart du
territoire français le Nord le
Pas-de-Calais la Picardie etc personne
n'aurait dit bah on va faire un plan
dans lequel on va donner un quart du
territoire français à l'Allemagne et on
va garder les trois quarts les Allemands
voulaient d'ailleurs autre chose ils en
voulaient plus et et les Français
évidemment ne pouvaient pas accepter ça
donc c'est pour ça que quel que soit les
gesticulations des uns et des autres et
les les Chinois travaillent leur image
aussi bien sûr quel que soit la
gesticulation des uns et des autres la
seule chose qui soit véritablement sur
la table c'est le rapport de force et
nous notre responsabilité c'est agir
pour que ce rapport de force soit
favorable aux Ukrainiens est-ce que vous
avez lu la chronique j'ai trouvé très
intéressante dans le monde ce matin de
Jonathan Lidl
je vais vous lire quelques un extrait
quelques extraits de synchronique de
dire ce que vous en pensez voilà ce
qu'il écrit nos pays ceux de l'ouest de
l'Europe en tout cas ne semblent
toujours pas avoir pris la mesure de la
menace existentielle qui pèse sur
l'Europe entière ce que vise Poutine ce
n'est pas que la conquête de l'Ukraine
c'est la défaite totale de notre système
de société de notre mode de vie avec nos
libertés notre ouverture notre
démocratie imparfaite mais indispensable
tout se passe comme si au cours des 70
dernières années de paix nous avions
oublié pourquoi l'Union européenne a été
créée pour empêcher que jamais une
guerre entre nation ne resurgit sur le
continent voilà ce qui crée Jonathan
nietanais et il pose la question
laisse-t-on croire à Poutine qui n'a pas
perdu la guerre oui je suis d'accord
avec cette avec cette analyse je suis en
désaccord avec Hubert Védrine qui dit
faut pas parler de guerre
civilisationnelle parce que ça nous
mènera le prix etc je crois que c'est ça
et le le pessimisme de de du texte que
vous venez de de lire mais pareil
justifier il y a écouté quand on regarde
géopolitiquement ce qui s'est passé au
cours des 30 dernières années
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique on
a le sentiment que nos valeurs le droit
à la démocratie etc l'emporte partout
c'est l'achat c'est fou cou couilles à
mâle afin de l'histoire les Chinois
évoluent dans le bon sens les Russes se
convertissent à la démocratie on aura
quelques temps plus tard le printemps
arabe tout ce qui fait le fond des
valeurs occidentales tout à coup semble
reconnu regardons ce qui s'est passé 30
ans plus tard on a perdu partout on a
reculé partout les Chinois ont connu
l'évolution qu'on connaît la Russie a
connu avec Poutine l'évolution tragique
que l'on voit le monde le monde arabe le
monde musulman c'est redit à la fois
dans le terrorisme islamiste d'un côté
et dans des régimes extraordinairement
répressifs et maintenant nous en sommes
à défendre nos valeurs sur le territoire
européen puisque l'Ukraine c'est sur le
territoire européen donc c'est comme si
notre notre champ idéologique était une
sorte de coach chagrin qui s'était
réduit
absolument vous avez raison il y a péril
dans l'admer et là je trouve je ne peux
pas discuter des retraites etc mais il y
a quand même une dissonance à mon avis
criante entre la nature de nos débats
intérieurs savoir si on doit travailler
un an de plus ou moins etc et l'ampleur
des déséquilibres et l'ampleur des
menaces qui pèse en France en Europe sur
ce qui fait le fond de notre
civilisation je finis je relis encore un
autre extrait vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez parce que j'ai trouvé
vraiment formidable quand quelqu'un vous
impose une guerre il n'y a qu'une
solution à gagner les Ukrainiens ont
raison 100 fois raison de dire que leur
sang défend l'Europe et quant à ceux qui
frémissent en invoquant la possibilité
d'une troisième guerre mondiale il est
grand temps qu'il comprenne que la
troisième guerre mondiale de par la
volonté de Vladimir Poutine est déjà là
et que nous sommes tous dedans l'Europe
et les États-Unis autant que la Chine et
les pays africains qui souffrent de la
fin provoqués par l'invasion russe et
les dictateurs soutenus par les
mercenaires du Kremlin
aussi une refuse de s'avouer vaincu mais
nous ne pouvons pas perdre non plus au
risque de voir tout ce à quoi nous
tenons le plus disparaître aucun de nous
ici en Europe ne peut vivre dans un
monde dans les règles darwiniennes
seraient dictées par la Russie par la
Chine un monde où le plus fort prendrait
ce qu'il voudrait et le faible n'aurait
qu'à se coucher ou mourir à nous donc de
décider que nous devons gagner la
victoire de l'Europe dans cette guerre
que nous n'avons pas choisie passe par
la victoire de l'Ukraine il faudrait
commencer par y croire oui moi j'ai
envoyé à la fin de l'année on fait des
lettres de vœux et j'ai envoyé k2e un
certain nombre de gens et j'avais pris
une citation de Charles Péguy celui qui
ne se rend pas à raison contre celui qui
se rend et cette phrase c'est une phrase
que j'avais en tête car elle avait été
fait l'objet d'un tract distribué dans
les rues de Brive de Brive-la-Gaillarde
le 17 juin le 17 juin 1940 la veille du
18 juin par Edmond Michelet grand
résistant devant et j'étais très lié le
personnellement avec mon Michelet qui
était un virement j'avais suivi avec
beaucoup d'admiration et cette phrase de
Peggy est absolument fondamental il faut
quand on est agressé il faut se battre
ce qui est ceux qui disent il faut
maintenant faire un des compromis etc
oublie que on est en face d'une
agression caractérisée vous pouvez pas
l'agresseur vous dit bah maintenant on
va négocier j'ai pris la moitié de votre
territoire bon ben je vais receder un
quart ou non c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe il y a eu il y a une faute un
crime contre la souveraineté de
l'Ukraine qui a été commis il faut que
ce crime soit effacé et tant qu'il ne le
sera pas tant qu'il ne le sera pas nous
devons rester vigilant et mobiliser au
service de nos amis la différence
peut-être c'est que ce qui me m'incite à
plus d'optimisme mais une petite nuance
c'est que je crois que cette surenchère
poutinienne sur le fond il est évident
qu'il déteste ce que nous sommes il
déteste la démocratie il déteste
l'égalité il déteste la lutte contre la
corruption il déteste tout ce qui fait
ce à quoi nous sommes attachés mais
silencieuxenché comme ça c'est un peu
parce qu'il a perdu aussi il en met il
en utilise nos faiblesses aussi pardon
j'enlève bien sûr qu'il a corruption
elle existe aussi chez nous vous le
savez c'est pas la même en Russie c'est
un sport de Moïse chez nous c'est un
sport d'élite on va dire oui oui ça
c'est pas mal comme ça oui oui Jean Le
bourge mais elle existe et il joue il
joue évidemment sur les travers de notre
de notre de nous société
occidentales
Jean-Luc bollange nous n'avons pas fait
preuve de beaucoup de lucidité il y a
quelques années face à Vladimir Poutine
franchement
on a on a espéré on a pris nos désirs
pour des réalités c'est pour ça que je
ne suis pas d'accord avec ce qui disent
maintenant ils le dis un peu moins mais
il a dit pendant longtemps comme Hubert
Védrine qui dit c'est nous qui avons pas
fait ce qu'il fallait n'avons pas fait
les gestes qu'il fallait si quand on
regarde par exemple un pays comme
l'Allemagne l'Allemagne c'est
impressionnant à quel point ils ont
dans l'idée qu'ils établissaient une
relation de confiance avec avec la
Russie à seulement schrodeur mais
d'ailleurs ils l'ont dit sigmari Gabriel
a dit c'est un fardeau personnel qui
pèse sur nous nous avons fait un choix
un choix
erroné le président de la République
c'est le meilleur il a dit aussi nous
avons fait une vue ils ont mesuré que en
faisant ce choix énergétique ce choix de
coopération ils ont fait preuve comme
Adil président de la République de
naïveté ça c'est vrai moi je suis pas
j'appartiens pas à l'école naïve je suis
je suis formé à aux disciplines
internationales par des gens comme
pierre hasner ou Raymond Aron qui que
Jean-Claude Casanova aujourd'hui nous
sommes à commentaires nous vous savez la
devise de commentaires c'est la phrase
de tussidi hein il y a pas de bonheur
sans liberté ni de liberté s'en
vaillance moi je crois profondément à la
vaillance je crois que si nous avons
réussi à triompher des de de l'URSS
pendant la guerre froide c'est parce que
nous avons été vigoureux fort etc et
depuis les années 90 on a bien vu que
tout partait en brioche qu'on avait plus
du tout le fighting spirit comme disent
les Américains on n'avait pas du tout la
conscience du monde dangereux et dans
lequel nous sommes et du fait que ce que
nous représentons et ce que nous aimons
ne peut pas être obtenu sans un effort
et sans une mobilisation permanente de
chacun d'entre nous merci Jean-Louis
bourge d'être venu nous voir ce matin
sur l'antenne vous êtes d'accord ou pas
d'accord à ce qui avec ce qui vient
d'être dit vous n'hésitez pas à un 0 826
300 300 dans un instant je serai en
direct avec
Anastasia pit palova qui ukrainienne qui
vit en France depuis 2011 je donnais des
chiffres tout à l'heure dans mon
introduction 115000
Ukrainiens en France dont 80% de femmes
300 à 500 arrivées par mois aujourd'hui
moins qu'avant évidemment 20800 enfants
qui sont scolarités enfants enfin
Ukrainiens qui sont scolarisés dans nos
écoles françaises Anastasia pit palova
ukrainienne vit en France depuis 2011
elle a travaillé en Russie sa famille
vit à Carson elle accueilli une partie
de sa famille et plusieurs de ses amis
sont encore en Ukraine il est 10h40 oui
j'en veux pour l'anglais invité il y a
très longtemps à déjeuner parce qu'il
était venu à Paris Boris namsov oui qui
a été assassiné dans les conditions j'y
pense avec beaucoup d'émotions bien sûr
Boris nous avait dit m'avait dit vous
êtes mou vous êtes mou à l'ouest vous ne
comprenez pas à quoi vous avez affaire
le combat pour la démocratie en Russie
est très importante c'est au début
période elle signe il faut absolument se
battre cesser de nous encourager à faire
preuve de réalité
un opposant politique
à vrai dire punting qui a été assassiné
sauvagement bien il est 10